cet été on a beaucoup bossé sur
tournesol et on a mis en ligne de
nouveaux algorithmes avec de meilleures
propriétés mathématiques et qui
s'appuient sur des principaux
philosophiques plus justifiés tout ça a
été documenté dans un article de
recherche qu'on a rendu disponible
gratuitement et librement sur la
plateforme Arcueil si vous êtes curieux
de savoir comment mêler mathématiques de
Traon haut niveau machine learning
philosophie morale et sciences
politiques le tout un carnet dans un
projet extrêmement concret et déployé
bah je vous invite à vous plonger dans
la lecture de cet article mais comme je
sais qu'il y en aura très certainement
au moins un parmi vous qui préfèrent une
présentation audiovisuelle des avancées
qu'on a effectué je vous propose de vous
expliquer les grandes lignes des
algorithmes de tournesol dans la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui et je vais essayer de
faire une présentation digeste ce qui
signifie que je vais devoir
malheureusement simplifier à outrance
certains aspects techniques et même
parfois être volontairement imprécis
voir légèrement
erronée dans mes explications allez
c'est parti
avant de parler des algorithmes faisons
un point rapide sur le projet tournesol
pour ce parmi vous qui n'en aura
toujours pas entendu parler tournesol
c'est une plateforme libre et open
source développée par l'association à
but non lucrative du même nom une
association qui est portée par une
équipe de bénévoles absolument
fantastique notamment Aidan lui Adrien
et d'autres j'ai l'honneur d'être
cofondateur et président de cette
association mais pour être clair je n'en
suis pas et prévoit de ne jamais en
devenir salarié en fait l'association
n'a pour l'instant qu'un seul salarié
qui est un développeur absolument
fantastique mais dont le salaire est
très loin d'être garanti sur la durée et
même sur le moyen voire le court terme
aujourd'hui on a la chance d'avoir le
soutien de beaucoup parmi vous ainsi que
celui d'infomaniac qui fournit
gratuitement des services informatiques
à l'association tournesol et qui
sponsorise cette vidéo en effectuant des
dons à l'association encore une fois je
ne suis qu'un bénévole dans cette
histoire je ne suis absolument pas
rémunéré pour cette vidéo que je produis
mais alors infomaniaque c'est quoi et
bien info maniaque c'est le service
cloud par excellence en Suisse qui se
démarque de la concurrence par son
éthique et sa TNT notamment par
opposition à d'autres services
américains ou chinois je vous conseille
en particulier la case 8 d'Infomaniak
qui contient toutes les applications
nécessaires pour collaborer en ligne
avec notamment un service mail et un
drive le tout entièrement développé et
hébergé en Suisse provenants au sol le
but de la plateforme c'est de proposer
une solution technique au problème
fondamental de la gouvernance des
intelligences artificielles qui me
semblent être de loin les plus
influentes d'aujourd'hui à savoir non
pas chaque GPT et midjorn donc
finalement qu'une influence limitée sera
géopolitique mondiale mais davantage les
IA de recommandations de Tik Tok
Instagram snapchat Twitter ou Youtube
qui elle détermine beaucoup plus quelles
informations auront beaucoup plus
l'attention du plus grand nombre et
quelles informations seront noyées dans
un océan de surabondance informationnel
en particulier pour de nombreuses causes
comme l'éducation la santé publique le
changement climatique la cybersécurité
la lutte contre la corruption ou la
défense des droits humains l'attention
de la population générale ou celle de la
population experte ou dirigeante et
critique pour protéger des millions
avoir des milliards de vie humaine on
l'a vu dans le cas du covid de la
canicule de la compromission de
Microsoft cloud du cathargate et du
Maroc gate ou encore dans le cas des
génocides des rohinga des Ouigours ou du
tigre l'inattention a de telles menaces
civilisationsnelles et extrêmement
dangereuse pour des milliards d'entre
nous vu le rôle prédominant qu'on acquis
les IA de recommandations dans
l'exposition informationnelle répétée
des milliards internautes humains il me
semble qu'il est désormais vain
d'espérer combattre cette inattention
sans s'attaquer à la conception à
l'éthique et à la sécurité de saisir
malheureusement comme le révèle
notamment les Facebook file au sujet
desquels je vous invite vivement à vous
informer si vous doutez du rôle des IA
sur les risques civilisationnels la
gouvernance hégémonique et unilatérale
de saisie à part des entreprises privées
est en train d'empêcher tout
contre-pouvoir démocratique sur le
comportement usuel de ses Ia
surpuissantes ceci étant dit même si
tout à coup la société civile avait le
pouvoir de modifier ses Ia il lui serait
aujourd'hui extrêmement difficile d'en
proposer une collaborative et sécurisée
le projet tournesol cherche justement à
modifier cet état de fait en permettant
une gouvernance collaborative sécurisée
et en temps réel désir de
recommandations en particulier tournesol
permet à n'importe lequel parmi vous de
contribuer pour faire en sorte que l'IA
de recommandations de tournesol
promeuvre les vidéos que vous jugez
préférable à recommander massivement au
grand public typiquement parce qu'il
s'agit de vidéos d'intérêt public enfin
ça c'est dans les grandes lignes car
quand on rentre dans le détail de
comment une tellia devrait se modifier
suite à l'ajout de jugement d'un
utilisateur sur Internet on tombe très
vite sur des questions fondamentales de
la science de l'information comme la
sécurité l'équité la transparence
l'interprétabilité ou encore
l'accessibilité de la gouvernance des
systèmes d'information à des
utilisateurs non experts en informatique
bien après maintenant trois ans de
travail sur les algorithmes de tournesol
on a fait énormément de progrès sur ces
questions et c'est le sujet de cette
vidéo même si comme on va le voir on est
encore extrêmement loin d'avoir une
solution pleinement satisfaisante
sur tournesol n’importe quelle
contribution de n'importe quelle
contributeur influencera les scores et
donc les recommandations faites par l'IA
de tournesol dans le jargon on parle de
système sans permission ou permission en
anglais cependant pour se protéger des
faux comptes contrôlés par des vagues de
troll il nous faut bien sûr limiter
l'influence des comptes pas suffisamment
certifiés c'est ainsi pour des raisons
de sécurité que sur tournesol certains
comptent n'auront parfois qu'un petit
droit de vote en informatique on parle
de résilience aux attaques civils du nom
d'un livre sur les troubles dissociatifs
de l'identité pour obtenir cette
résilience civile tournesol s'appuie sur
deux données de certification la
résilience civile du nom de domaine de
l'adresse email de l'utilisateur et les
parrainages entre utilisateurs ainsi
tournesol adresser une liste de noms de
domaine de confiance comme atpfl.ch ou
at inria.fr la particularité de ces noms
de domaines étant que d'après
l'association tournesol il semble
difficile pour des entités malveillantes
de contrôler un grand nombre de
messageries électroniques avec de
domaine et ça c'est bien sûr par
opposition à adjamil.com ou approton.me
puisqu'il suffit de quelques clics pour
n'importe qui pour créer un grand nombre
de messageries de la sorte voilà qui
permet d'assigner une pré-confiance à
certains comptes tournesols l'autre
méthode de certification sur tournesol
et le parrainage si vous manquez de
confiance sur tournesol typiquement
parce que vous n'avez pas d'adresse
email avec un nom de domaine résilient
aux attaques civils alors vous pouvez
demander aux amis typiquement des amis
qui ont de telles adresses d'aller sur
tout seul de créer un compte et d'aller
se porter garant pour vous via
l'interface de tournesol le parrainage
permet ensuite de tracer un graphe
orienté où l'on mène une flèche d'un
utilisateur vers un autre si le premier
utilisateur a parrainer le second
tournesol propose ensuite de diffuser la
confiance à travers ce réseau de
confiance plus précisément on utilise un
nouvel algorithme appelé lipshitrust
pour diffuser cette confiance qui est
une variante plus sécurisée de
l'algorithme péjrong qui a fait la
fortune de Google cette confiance est
ensuite convertie droit de vote sur
chaque vidéo de la manière suivante
tournesol d'abord la confiance totale
des contributeurs à la vidéo puis on va
s'autoriser à assigner légèrement plus
de droits de vote cet excédent qu'on
s'autorise est alors répartie entre les
comptes qui manquent de confiance voilà
qui nous permet de garantir que l'impact
cumulé des comptes douteux sera toujours
limité tout en permettant d'intégrer les
jugements des comptes pas suffisamment
certifiés avec possiblement des droits
de vote quasi unitaire pour les vidéos
qui ne sont évaluées que par une poignée
de compte de la sorte
pour estimer la recommandabilité des
différentes vidéos YouTube tournesol
s'appuie sur un jugement comparatif des
contributeurs parce que ceci nous semble
plus fiable que des jugements par vidéo
par ailleurs de tels jugements
comparatifs répondent davantage à la
question fondamentale de tournesol qui
notamment via l'extension fait un
ensemble de quatre commandements à
chaque utilisateur à chaque fois que
celui-ci ouvre la page youtube.com sur
son navigateur condition bien sûr que
l'utilisateur a au préalable installé
l'extension tournesol qui est disponible
sur Firefox Chrome et Edge quand on fait
un nombre limité de recommandations la
question fondamentale n'est pas de
savoir si telle ou telle vidéo est bien
la question fondamentale c'est davantage
de savoir quelle vidéo devrait le plus
souvent apparaître dans ce rectangle
jaune des recommandations de tournesol
ceci étant dit pour répondre à cette
question tournesol s'appuie en fait sur
le calcul de score pour chaque vidéo à
partir de ces comparaisons il nous faut
donc une façon de transformer des
comparaisons en score à ce sujet il y a
peut-être des utilisateurs de Twitter
parmi vous qui se souviennent de mon
tweet où j'annonçais de manière la
cryptique une découverte magnifique que
le mathématicien Julien fajo et moi
avions alors faites et bien cette
découverte concerne justement cette
transformation de comparaison en score
vient formalisme en fait assez général
et très élégant qu'on a appelé generald
Bradley et qu'on a décrit dans un autre
article de recherche également
disponible sur arcade et qui a reçu
depuis les contributions également des
excellents saddock fadeccanique et Oscar
villemom parmi les nombreuses propriétés
remarquables de cette famille de
transformation de comparaison en score
il y a la monotonicité que Julien a
démontré et qui garantit que si vous
accentuez votre préférence de a contre B
alors la note de a va nécessairement
augmenter et celle de B nécessairement
décroître ça paraît tout bête dit comme
ça mais il se trouve que les modèles
qu'on avait avant cet été et bien
n'avait pas assez de propriété ce qui
faisait que parfois mettre des jugements
trop extrêmes n'avaient pas tout à fait
l'influence souhaitée et ça a d'ailleurs
conduit plusieurs contributeurs de
tournesol parmi nous notamment moi même
à juger les vidéos de manière pas tout à
fait honnête
faire une vidéo a été largement
meilleure qu'une autre disait pas
forcément qui a été largement meilleur
parce qu'il était plus efficace de dire
qu'elle était seulement meilleur grâce à
cette nouvelle famille d'algorithme
generas Bradley ça a été d'incitation à
la malhonnêteté et heureusement révolue
ainsi à l'aide de ses nouveaux
algorithmes GBT les comparaisons de la
contributeur sont transformés en score
du contributeur que vous pouvez
d'ailleurs afficher si le contributeur
les a rendus public en allant notamment
à l'adresse tourne seul.apps/
user/identifiant d'utilisateur slash
recommandation voici par exemple mais
top recommandation
il y aurait d'ailleurs beaucoup plus à
dire sur un merveilleuse structure
mathématique que Julien et moi avons
découvertes mais bon ça va prendre un
peu de temps à expliquer et du coup je
vais laisser ça pour une prochaine vidéo
pour que la gouvernance de tournesol
soit vraiment collaboratif il faut bien
évidemment à un moment donné agréger les
avis des différents contributeurs mais
s'il y a une chose qu'on a appris en
développement tournesol que j'avais déjà
un peu à exploré dans la série sur la
démocratie c'est que les mathématiques
de l'agrégation d'avis conflictuels sont
extrêmement complexes surtout si l'on
veut faire cela de manière éthique et
sécurisée qui plus est dans un contexte
Sparte c'est-à-dire dans un contexte où
chaque contenu n'est évalué que par une
infime minorité des contributeurs voire
des contenus par aucun des contributeurs
en particulier d'un point de vue équité
une telle agrégation se doit d'éviter
les pièges des jugements parisiens et
Marseillais et oui c'est littéralement
le nom que je donne aux problèmes
fondamental de la comparabilité des
jugements de différents contributeurs
dans mes conférences académiques
imaginez ainsi un excellent contenu qui
attire disproportionnément plus de
contributeurs parisiens ils faisons
l’hypothèse complètement imaginaire que
ces contributeurs parisiens sont
victimes du maladies qui les poussent à
systématiquement râler même lorsque
contenu qui sont censés évaluer sont
d'une qualité exceptionnelle si on
utilise des agrégations naïves des
jugements des contributeurs cette
excellent contenu pourra recevoir
presque exclusivement des avis négatifs
non pas parce que le contenu est mauvais
mais parce qu'il attire des
contributeurs qui disposent d'un biais
systématique de négativité et du coup ça
ne serait pas vraiment juste faisons
maintenant une autre hypothèse
complètement imaginaire elle aussi
imaginez que les contributeurs
Marseillais sont victimes d'une autre
maladie qu'il épouse à constamment
exagéré leur jugement pour eux il n'y a
pas d'entre-deux un contenu et ou bien
excellentissime ou bien honteusement
merdique un contenu correct jugé
quasiment exclusivement par de telles
contributeurs sera jugé excellentissime
davantage à cause de la manière dont
ceux qui l'ont jugé s'expriment qu'à
cause de sa qualité intrinsèque et bien
il y a quelques années Youssef a loi
Oscar villemo Rachid guerraoui et
moi-même avons formaliser ces
difficultés et ajouter une exigence de
sécurité qu'on appelle depuis la
résilience litchi cette résidence
lipshitz exige que chaque contributeur
pourra influencer le score d'une vidéo
d'opus une quantité proportionnelle à
son droit de vote très concrètement
surtout en au sol ça correspond en gros
à 10 points pour un droit de vote
unitaire et bien avec mes collaborateurs
on a conçu une solution à ce problème un
scrutin qu'on appelle aujourd'hui mais
Stan du nom d'un protoparlement en Iran
antique autour de 247 après Jésus-Christ
là encore il y aurait beaucoup plus à
dire sur cet algorithme que je
présenterai plus en détail dans une
prochaine vidéo il s'agit en tout cas à
quelques adaptations près de la manière
dont tournesol a choisi d'agréger les
avis des différents contributeurs
des aspects les plus insatisfaisants des
algorithmes pré-estivaux c'est qu'ils a
signé un score négatif à de nombreuses
vidéos qui étaient plutôt bonnes
notamment des vidéos de sciences
étonnantes souvent simplement parce que
celle-ci ne traite pas d'un sujet que
les contributeurs de tournesol juge
important autrement dit beaucoup de
vidéos recommandables mais parce
qu'elles ne sont pas les plus
recommandables donnez l'impression
d'être jugé négativement sur la
plateforme parfois très négativement ce
qui la foule un peu mal quand j'essaie
d'approcher des youtubeurs leur dire que
ton seul c'est chouette en fait ce que
nous avons fini par comprendre c'est que
le problème résidait davantage dans le
fait que la vidéo moyenne sur tournesol
avait un score de zéro qui se trouve
aussi être le score par défaut en
l'absence de tout jugement notre
solution pour corriger le tir et
simplement de modifier le score par
défaut pour qu'il ne correspondent pas à
une vidéo moyenne sur tournesol mais
pour qu'il corresponde davantage à une
mauvaise vidéo de tournesol autrement
dit le score par défaut égal à zéro va
correspondre à une vidéo parmi les 15%
les moins bonnes de la plateforme en
quelque sorte comme si on instauré une
présomption de positivité pour 85% des
vidéos de tournesol estimation qu'on a
fait remplir avec moi à la louche
l'association tournesol s'est dit que il
y a quand même en gros 85% des vidéos
sur ton sol qui sont recommandables de
façon intéressante ceci nous a permis de
programmer naturellement une présomption
de non recommandabilité sur la
plateforme en fixant un seuil de
recommandabilité à 20 autrement dit ton
seul va s'autoriser à recommander une
vidéo uniquement si son score dépasse 20
ce qui est intéressant c'est que par
construction pour devenir recommandable
un contenu va devoir recevoir
suffisamment de jugement positifs de
suffisamment de contributeurs en effet
chaque contributeur a un droit de vote
au plus égal à 1 sur tournesol or la
garantie de résilience lipshit fait que
un droit de vote unitaire ne peut
déplacer le score d'une vidéo que de un
petit peu moins de 10 9,95 mais du coup
deux droits de vote ne peuvent avoir un
effet que de 19,9 ce qui ne sera pas
suffisant pour devenir une vidéo
recommandable selon tournesol là c'est
en fait typiquement un cas de mensonge
par sur simplification et vous invite à
aller voir les détails
si vous voulez avoir la version plus
rigoureuse il me semble y avoir quelque
chose d'en fait très profond derrière
cette notion de présomption de non
recommandabilité surtout à l'air de la
surabondance de l'information sera de
surcroît alimentée par l'explosion des
algorithmes génératifs et
l'enrichissement spectaculaire du
cybercrim plutôt que de chercher à
signaler et retirer le mauvais il est
peut-être devenu plus judicieux de
permettre la diffusion massive
uniquement pour des contenus qui auront
été jugés adéquats à diffusés
massivement selon suffisamment de
jugement humain surtout quand il s'agit
de sujets importants comme la santé
publique le changement climatique ou le
respect des droits humains quoi qu'il en
soit ce sont les scores calculés selon
tout le processus que je viens de
décrire qui sont affichés sur le site
Web de tournesol et via l'extension des
navigateurs Firefox Chrome et Edge et ce
sont également ses scores qui sont
utilisés pour déterminer quel contenu
seront plus souvent affichés dans le
rectangle jaune des recommandations
tournesol
j'espère que la vidéo d'aujourd'hui vous
aide à mieux comprendre comment
tournesol envisage la sécurité d'une
gouvernance collaborative des IA les
plus puissantes du monde moderne en
particulier plus que des algorithmes
dédiés à la plateforme tournesol les
nombreuses difficultés et solutions dont
j'ai parlé me semble
omniprésente dès lors que l'on cherche à
permettre à des internautes de prendre
des décisions collectives de nombreux
projets participatifs en ligne
gagneraient ainsi sans doute à
s’inspirer de nos travaux que ce soit au
niveau de la certification des comptes
de l'inférence des préférences des
contributeurs de l'agrégation des avis
contraires ou de la présentation des
résultats de cette agrégation ceci étant
dit il serait très erroné de voir un
tournesol une solution complète à la
gouvernance algorithmique en fait jusque
là j'ai surtout l'impression qu'on a
fait à peine plus que le strict minimum
pour avoir une solution à peu près
fonctionnelle et relativement sécurisé
mais pour disposer d'une solution
vraiment fiable et efficace de
gouvernance algorithmique de nombreux
autres enjeux doivent être résolus ce
qui va nécessiter beaucoup plus de
recherches en amont aussi bien sur le
plan mathématique que sur les plans
philosophiques sociologiques politiques
juridique et psychologique comme on en
parle notamment dans notre article
histoire de citer trois de ces nombres
défis en premier lieu où on aimerait
inclure des jugements directs de
recommandabilité et de non
recommandabilité des vidéos ce qui
permettrait de collecter beaucoup plus
de données quoi que de moindre qualité
que les données de comparaison mais il
faudra alors concevoir des algorithmes
capables de combiner les deux types
d'informations ce qui à ma connaissance
n'existe pas par ailleurs l'avantage de
ces jugements directs c'est qu'il
s'agirait d'informations exploitables
pour apprendre automatiquement comment
ajuster le 0 plutôt que de laisser
l'association tournesol choisir de
manière unilatérale le chiffre de 85%.
en seconde lieu on aimerait implémenter
une démocratie liquide sur tournesol qui
permettrait à chacun de transférer ses
droits de vote à des personnes plus
actives sur la plateforme ou
d'identifier des experts pour telle ou
telle vidéo et de leur déléguer tout ou
partie des droits de vote de telles
données nous permettrait aussi de
construire des réseaux d'expertise et
d'ident des experts sur tel ou telle
question ce qui permettrait de rendre la
plateforme plus épistocratique notamment
sur des sujets particulièrement
techniques comme le changement
climatique la santé publique ou encore
la cybersécurité enfin un troisième défi
est d'établir des fondations plus
solides et plus profondes de tournesol
que cherche-t-on vraiment à faire sur
cette plateforme comment intégrer ceux
qui ne s'y sont pas beaucoup exprimés
est-ce vraiment les préférences
instinctives de tout le monde qu'il nous
faut apprendre et combiner comment
justifier de manière implacable la
valorisation de l'expertise et que
signifie concrètement cette valorisation
au niveau de la conception de la
plateforme comment mesure-t-on les
déviations entre ce qui est calculé par
plateforme et ce qu'on aimerait avoir
calculé quelles sont les propriétés
qu'une gouvernance vraiment
satisfaisante doit satisfaire j'ai
beaucoup de bout de réponse à ces
nombreuses questions mais je suis le
premier à admettre que je suis très loin
d'avoir une réponse limpide et qu'il y a
clairement d'énormes progrès à faire
dans cette direction de fondation de la
gouvernance algorithmique
bref comme on le disait en 2019 dans
notre livre le fabuleux chantier rendre
les intelligences artificielles
robustement bénéfiques est un chantier
absolument monumental qui requiert une
pluridisciplinaire réalité dont la
recherche académique aujourd'hui a été
trop peu prompte à initier et très
inefficace à accomplir en fait l'un des
grands objectifs à court et moins
interne de tournesol c'est justement d'y
parvenir si vous êtes mathématicien
informaticien philosophe sociologue ou
psychologue je vous invite à vous
intéresser de plus près à notre projet
et à rejoindre la communauté
grandissante de mathématiciens
d'informaticiens de philosophe de
sociologue et de psychologue qui
cherchent collaborativement à concevoir
les fondations d'une gouvernance
algorithmique affective efficace et
sécurisée et à résoudre les nombreux
problèmes aussi bien théoriques que
pratiquent qu'une telle gouvernance
soulève mais pour y arriver j'ai une
dernière demande à vous faire et c'est
une demande financière si l'on veut
continuer à développer tournesol il nous
faut absolument avoir les moyens
financiers pour y parvenir or
malheureusement malgré les nombreuses
aides de bénévoles parmi vous et les
dons d'infomaniaques l'association
tournesol est aujourd'hui quasiment à
sec à moins d'une aide significative de
votre part nous ne pourrons plus assurer
le salaire de notre employé et dans les
mois à venir nous devrons nous passer de
ces services pourtant excellentissime
pour soutenir et encourager la recherche
sur la gouvernance collaborative et
sécurisée des algorithmes et mener au
mieux nos projets de démocratie liquide
d'apprentissage de la pollution et de
fondation mathématiques nous vous
saurions extrêmement reconnaissants de
bien vouloir contribuer à nos finances
si bien sûr vous en avez les moyens via
des dons directs à l'association via
notre plateforme qu'est-ce qui se bain
nous vous en remercions beaucoup
d'avance